We are back with a new episode
of the Wine Down.
And today we are joined
by Kendrick Sampson
who plays Nathan,
to discuss, "Lowkey Trying."
♪ (UPBEAT MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
So Issa and Nathan
have a big heart-to-heart
this episode.
Do you think Nathan
still has lingering feelings
for Issa?
-Yeah, yeah.
-(ALL LAUGHING)
I mean, you know, he--
he also has like guilt,
you know?
He went away for a minute
to figure his shit out
and then all of a sudden
he's back.
And he's in an intimate space
-with her.
-Is it unreasonable of him
to expect that
she wouldn't move on?
Like the reaction to hearing
that she was back with Lawrence
-was mad shady.
-Nah, I think it's one
of those things, especially
since he thinks
he has everything together,
where you like, "I'm good,
you know, whatever happens
happens."
You know, and when
it actually comes face-to-face
you're like, "Hold up,
you for real?"
-Yeah.
-"Oh, so you're just gonna
move on like that?"
But it's also a very dude thing
to put him down immediately.
-(ALL LAUGHING)
-It's like--
-KENDRICK: 100 percent.
-"Oh, like the dude that, like,
ain't got no shoes.
Like, yeah,
well that's who you're with?
Like--"
You know, even if you're like
over it,
you still gotta be like,
"But I'm better."
Also, from Nathan's perspective,
you guys have been starting
to kick it a little bit.
So like in his mind it's like,
"Okay, I helped you
with the block party,
I called you afterwards,
you came by my shop,
we kicked it at the game night."
You know what I mean?
-So it's like--
-There's some hope.
There's some hope that like,
"Oh, maybe us kicking it
is like going somewhere."
So it is like a little bit of--
Like, "I ain't doing this
for you to reciprocate,
but if you do...
I ain't gonna be mad at it."
You know?
But it was also like
Nathan was like
dropping little things, like,
"Well I did give you the idea."
(ALL LAUGHING)
For the block party, you know?
He's definitely
just reminding her, yeah.
Just gently reminding her
-how dope he was.
-Like... (CHUCKLES)
"I was just playing,
but for real, you know--
I did give you the idea."
How does Issa's perception
of how he ghosted change
once she learns
the reason why
is he's also bipolar?
Yeah, I think that
that puts so much
in perspective.
I think it goes
from a typical millennial
dating experience
of a man not being able
to use his words
and then coming back around,
all of a sudden,
-to be like, "We good, right?"
-(CHUCKLES) Right.
To like, "Oh, he actually had
personal mental health issues
that he needed to deal with.
And he needed to take the time
to do that. You-- You become
more understanding
because, you know,
we start off this season
in a very self-reflective way,
with Issa being like,
"Self-care Sunday"
and I think in some ways
that might have been a bit
superficial, and here's,
you know, someone
who's dealing with something
where he actually needed
to take care of himself.
-Real self-care.
-Is that superficial?
I mean self-care Sunday--
Like, we actually do have
to take care of ourselves,
and sometimes
that's kind of the debate
that I'm going
back and forth with.
Like, should she be with him,
or not? You know, um,
what would I do
in this situation?
And all that kind of stuff
is just like, people have
mental health issues
and it's not necessarily
as scary as a lot of people
would think it is.
Um, there's a full spectrum
of-- of mental health issues.
But at the same time,
we have to factor in
our own health,
and how we deal with people.
And just realize
it's just another thing,
you know?
True.
How do you approach,
and how does it feel
playing a char--
a Black man, with--
with mental health issues?
I mean the way I--
I see it,
you can't grow up in America
and be Black
and not have some sort
of mental health problems.
Whether it's PTSD, or something.
So it was important
for me to play this.
It was important
for me to have this
as a discussion,
a conversation starter,
and also to amplify those--
those issues
that are important to me.
You know you and I
had conversations,
we had conversations
in the room about, you know,
how do we reveal this,
how do we do this,
or does it feel like a...
(IMITATES GLOOMY MUSIC)
You know what I mean?
As a-- as a thing,
and how do you honor it,
how we do de-stigmatize it?
How do we play it as like,
"This is one thing
I'm dealing with,
but it doesn't, you know,
define me."
You know what I mean?
And I believe we did a good job
in terms
of how it comes out,
and how we talked about it.
Um, at least on the page,
and I believe
in the performances as well.
So it doesn't feel
like we're doing a mic drop
of a thing.
That we're just saying, "Hey,
this isn't a thing
that we need to like
make you just--
You know, it's an issue,
but it's not, yes,
this giant plot point
in that way.
And it's a part of his life
that he's dealing with
like a lot of us are, you know?
-Yeah.
It provides some nuance.
And y'all did a good job
with that, you know...
-ISSA: Thank you for your help.
-(ALL LAUGHING)
But-- Well thank you
so much again
for joining us
for another episode
of the Wine Down.
Please join us next week
for the final episode
of the season.
You don't want to miss it,
see you soon.
-Cheers. One more.
-Cheers!
Penultimate!
♪ (MUSIC CONCLUDES) ♪